a you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network now it's an
American history podcast in each week I
read a story from American history to my
friend Gareth Reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about and
your name is Dave Anthony that's right
I'm head of HR of the dollop and I'm
also one of the hosts of the show all
right let's just and as as we
understanding yesterday through text you
need to leave this bit off air you need
to see HR nope I'm not gonna keep doing
it you talked to what you talked to
draft you talked to a pig how many how
many characters told you to go see HR
yesterday in that text far too many for
a man of your age to be sending we are
brought to you by modern is CBT dot-com
CBD you you have experience DVD is great
and these this CV product is great not
only did I enjoy it my mother Pam
enjoyed it yeah and and our my neighbor
has a dog with horrible hip problems its
German Shepherd takes CBD could barely
move now is just like cruising around I
mean it's it's it's really I tried to
keep it illegal for so uh so modern CBD
calm you know they're they're there to
help you CBD pain relief anxiety sleep
all kinds of stuff it helps with and so
what they do is they're sir curating to
find the best CD CBD products and they
test the sources they make sure it's
from reputable sources because there's a
lot of CBD out there and you don't know
if it's good or not so these guys are
basically checking it out making sure
it's good and then you can buy from them
and everybody's happy
it's a better better time than it used
to be that's right it's a website for
your seat CBD products free shipping on
all orders only the top-selling brands
that use USA growing hemp full
transparency with product lab results
available on-site 100% customer
satisfaction guarantee boom boom it's
really good
I definitely sampled quite a bit get
your CBD products today I think it's so
many different ways the way that you can
ingest stuff in it like the amount of
there's gummies there's the liquids
there's oil yes there's bones for dogs
yeah it's crazy there's a little bit a
little bacon treats yeah get your CBD
products today from CDR in CBD with a
special offer for our listeners go to
CDR n CBD calm that's M dr n CBD calm
and enter my code our code the Dalek for
30% off your order and shipping is free
that's MDR in CBD calm with code dollop
of for 30% off MDR n CBD calm promo code
adult for 30% off your first order huh
and called it quote is jam-packed
shipped and I'm the [ __ ] hippo guy
Dave okay Ames guarantee but it's good
and this is not gonna come particularly
podcast yeah you both resent sick
argument
no unless he died my friend
yeah man that's a theme song hot
you got tour dates oh yeah this weekend
I'll be at laughs Boston in Boston July
19th and 20th doing three shows then
July 26th 27th 28th I'll be at the
Denver improv I again I will not be
there August 9th through the 11th then
I'll be at Acme comedy club Minneapolis
Minnesota July 30th through August 3rd
Seattle Washington August 17th the
Fremont a B and then comedy club on
State Madison Wisconsin August 22nd
through the 24th 24th record album come
on yeah yeah and the DA will be in
Irvine and San Diego in August San Jose
and September has been canceled because
they decided to do some work which oh by
the way place and as we're having work
done to ourselves in a retaliatory
fashion so you and I are both getting
nose jobs and chin lifts that's right
and I'm getting my butt chin that's
right it's all happening but we'll be
we'll still be going in to Sacramento I
see in September and then we do Madison
and Milwaukee in October and then we
head to Europe Stockholm Oslo Amsterdam
Glasgow Manchester London Birmingham
Cardiff Dublin Copenhagen you can find
all of those tickets links at dollop
podcast calm I know there was a problem
with the with the site on mobile it has
now been fixed so we're calling it the
pronounciation tour yeah it's gonna be a
bummer for everybody for everybody you
want to watch this gonna be all things
come to YouTube page there's a lot of
great things on there Jacob we also
brought to you by a rake on look it's
2019 what does everybody need what's the
bit I tell you the best thing I've
gotten ear buds your butt your butt
technology is the best thing happening
right now but before you go drop in a
hundreds of dollars on a pair you need
to check out Raycom here las' not
earless wireless earbuds no earless hard
did they're hard to find
will you you ok so you've been using the
rake on i've never had any product like
this
I've run from technology most of my why
remember I was telling you about your
list yeah we had arguments where most
people didn't hear it some people did
and they were like why do you guys argue
and you know yeah it's because I wanted
I wanted to try this I knew I've been
talking about yeah you'd been like a
wireless earbuds no like something above
my head that I kept reaching for yeah
and then uh and they're awesome they are
I don't know if I'm sure a lot of people
maybe know about these things but
they're awesome yeah so so Garris now in
love with his redcon earbuds now they
one of the guys yeah you're one of the
guys they start about half the price as
other premium wireless earbuds and they
sound great
yeah I test him out they sound amazing
they've been in your ears well I had to
test them to make sure we want to do the
do the product we're not just going to
product trying it and right I licked
them ray cons he 50 wireless earbuds
have totally changed the game for for
you especially yes your game has changed
there's no the old games gone they're
both stylish they're discreet there's no
wires hanging down which is the main
thing and they look great and they sound
great
so they're offering their wireless
earbuds for everyone in a range of fun
colors at an unbeatable price so go buy
rake on Comm
slash dollop to get 15% off your order
that's a buy rake on Comm slash dollop
for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds if
you've been eyeing a pair now is the
time to get an amazing deal one more
time by rake on Comm slash dollar though
and we also brought to you by joy bird
obviously I'm a huge fan of joy bird we
have joy bird my wife this whole office
is joy bird now because we got a chair
pick chair it's two dogs in a person I'm
that person and where's your hey trust
me it's good and and then my wife liked
the chair so much she's like I'm doing
my whole office in this and she they're
great because they have all kinds of
colors and you can all kinds of fabrics
that you can use and you can you know
build it with them they got these
concierge type people that help
get on the phone with them they talk you
through it will need how's it working
and and it's great it's really awesome
you don't have to go to a store and deal
with some guy who's trying to sell you a
piece of furniture he's been trying to
get rid of what about this turquoise
chairs it's a good one what about a
fold-up people saying futon is dead I
personally I don't see it
so they got quality handcrafted
furniture each each piece made by hand
take the party outside with their unique
outdoor collection yeah 365 home day
trial skip the furniture store and bring
the showroom home so you can sleep on it
you can step on it you can well if I
shouldn't but you can break it in sure
and if you don't love it return it for a
full refund hassle-free and home
delivery free returns within two weeks
of delivery so it's all good yeah just
Saul has a great yeah
see how joy bird can help you design
your dream space find out your joy today
at joy Burt calm / promo create the
furniture that brings you joy today at
joy bird comm / dog go to joy board calm
/ top and receive an exclusive offer for
25% off your first order by using code
dollop though we also brought to you by
Casper a mattress company the best you
sleep on a Casper yeah he's the bigger
baby yeah and I got my data Casper you
did yeah yeah and he loves it the DA was
brought to you in part by Casper's new
hybrid mattresses which combine the
pressure relief of their award-winning
foam with durable yet gentle springs oh
I thought it was the half human half
mattress thing we were talking that's
that's coming later right if he so you
like you said you know that you don't
have a hybrid though you just got the
regular yeah well cat the hybrid is a it
sounds like a step up
Casper products are cleverly designed to
mimic human curves providing supportive
comfort for all kinds of ball in it
mimics my human curve this is
uncomfortable
everybody stop just say it mimics my the
breathable design
[Laughter]
ah ha let's roll let's roll one of these
the breathable design helps you sleep
cool and regulate your body temperature
throughout the night
Casper now offers four other mattresses
the way the essential the hybrid Casper
and the hybrid wave so there's a lot
going on over a Casper the Casper I
think is a castle - Casper Castle yes
the wave features a patent-pending
premium support system to mirror the
natural shape of your body the essential
has streamlined design at a price that
won't keep you up at night the hybrids
combine the pressure relief of the
award-winning foam with durable yet
gentle springs delivery to your door and
the crazy box that you open up and then
it becomes a live mattress right right
here you may now sleep on me that's
right so go get to fifty dollars towards
select mattresses by visiting Casper
comm slash top and using a dollop at
checkout that's Casper comm slash dollop
and use code dollop at checkout terms
and conditions apply
we're also brought to you by Squarespace
how much do we like Squarespace well we
have Squarespace as our own personal
websites each of us we also have a
Squarespace as our source page and we
have a square space as our dollop page
for the podcast where you can get
tickets to all of our live shows see I
slipped that in it's called looking
professional smooth daddy-o
you can turn your cool it into a new
website you can showcase your work you
can blog or publish content sell
products and services of all kinds
promote your physical and online
business announced an upcoming event
whatever you want to do Squarespace is
the place to do it I think I create
templates 24/7 award-winning service
built in search engine analytics it's
all there it's all happening what do you
look like you're gonna say something
okay
and they're also nice people I know
people over there who've had a
relationship hi Jessica
for years with some of the Squarespace
people I'm over there all the time
sup Chad how's that macaroni salad dude
lol so go over to Squarespace comm for
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code dollop to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that squarespace.com enter
code dollop and you can go to our pages
and check them out and see the great
work that we've
on our sites yeah with Squarespace I
just
and I just real quick want to play a
song that I was given recently that's
okay either so there's good music out
there about us so go find it wow what if
um what if this podcast did not what if
this did not get onto my loud like it
should have what's the date you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
the last date it's it's I mean this
cannot be we might just have to do the
English one okay and then are you
available today you know yes let me make
sure we got a fight on Aaron's schedule
- what's your schedule Wow it will have
to do it at my house
okay let me see today's the 16th yeah I
can do one later
no maybe this is okay what maybe this
maybe that date was wrong
they just check to make sure I got to
find Roy let me find Roy for what the
Roy stuffs in here we're good to go
all right the date of the date was just
off it's not July 1st right no how do
you how do you like these kind of delays
Aaron is just good for you
yeah okay yeah we're good to go all
right September 8 1922 here of our Lord
Jesus Christ this is a religious podcast
I'd rather enough and we are spreading
the word of Jesus alright let's just
which is what yeah I mean it's not I'm
not
yeah it's yes okay it's except God let's
go Lynden her mile Alerus jr. was born
in Rochester New Hampshire I'm gonna
need one more take of the name Linden
her mile LaRouche jr. okay cuz he here
at once you're like we got to give my
son this name I could have it could be
her Mele but I really doubt it
yeah had it been a family name right yes
you don't just you don't throw that on a
kid well I mean like unless you're in
the bathtub doing a bunch of opium born
in Rochester New Hampshire as parents
Orthodox Quakers as well as really
really fervent anti-communist s-- I'm
really against communists okay
while many Quakers are known for their
tolerance linden was from the other
strain of Quakers okay so he was his
parents sent him he's not the oatmeal
kind he's not the happy
Quakers that we know and love him oh
that's an interesting policy how about
we break bread he studies like kill him
let's go break bones his parents said
him to Quaker summer camps oh what a
nightmare
but not for enjoyment know that nobody's
there for enjoyment he had orders to
organize other campers against a
Bolshevik sympathizing counselors so
what kind of camp is this it's just a
new amp but he's there it's a regular
camp but he's been sent in to find
communists as you do with children how
old is he he's been it's when he's a kid
he's like you know and he's there to
sniff out communists at his camp yeah
what would you do again
probably probably just starting some did
you
it's not send you out to find communists
in summer camps I mean I was there there
was probably another kid doing that I
was just on like well that makes me
wonder in the water what kind of family
you can't like a commie of you from a
communist family no do you love America
yeah Lyndon was heavily bullied but his
parents said he did not fight back due
to Quaker pacifism and he's also a
pacifist
wait okay there's a lot of you can find
you can root out the Communists but when
you find him if they push you walk away
head held high yeah your password okay
what was that that was my was that you
that was me boy I'm made of mainly
Springs this led to more bullying as it
quote became a challenge to those who
speculated on exactly how much abuse I
would tolerate Wow
so that's you know that's not great no
in 1932 the family moved to the Boston
suburb of Lynn okay in 1941
Linden's father was expelled from the
Quakers for publishing rambling
conspiracy filled accusations against
other local Quakers as well as support
for Hitler well this is developing
nicely isn't it this is really coming
along okay so yeah well we're I'm on
side Quaker here yeah this is not
classic Quaker behavior no this guy's
rogue Linden and his mother resigned in
solidarity from the Quakers right okay
but they weren't like necessarily giving
Hitler shoutouts they were just like
we're with dad or you know maybe maybe
they weren't a Hitler who knows sure
sure and they're not right in the
letters but I would imagine you're
getting brainwashed quite a bit with
your dad your Hitler living dad [ __ ]
don't I know it
mmm in fall 1941 Lyndon went to college
at Northeastern University he lasted one
year I got in there oh you did yeah
that's a bad sign yeah he was quote
disgusted with the methodological of
methodological methodological
incompetence of most of my courses and
the general Phyllis tinny ISM
accompanying them
okay so blabbity blah it's a lot limited
Eastern talked you and get it yeah I
wouldn't get it at all
Lenin then declared himself a world war
two conscientious objector but he got
bored and he fell in with the Indian
Communist Party so sorry
I messed that up he groped grew bored in
1944 he joined the army serving as a
medic in Burma India okay and while he
was in Calcutta he fell in with the
Indian Communist Party but it so he is
yeah go ahead
you seen something here well if I'm
seeing a 180 degree spin that's right
so it's he's rebelling and it was dad's
whole thing is anti-communism he's gonna
he's gonna as kids try to find one
against is there specific a specific
moment he's rebelling against that's
just in general how his dad's kind of
casually bringing up Hitler a lot of
dinners yeah would be like it's pretty
good though I mean hey you know what
else is good
Hitler good meatloaf but he'll they're
also pretty good yeah so he's you know
the wars on he's in he's in Kolkata
there's some cool communist around sure
so by the time he leaves India in 1946
he was quote a hardened Trotskyist okay
so time to go see daddy
so trusk ISM is a Marxist ideology based
on the theory of permanent revolution
okay boy
endless believes in an economic system
sort of Beyond Borders is like a world
system sure rather than national one
right and that the working class has had
job hegemony over the revolutionary
class right so it's a little bit
different in some other ways right look
at it okay
so it's pretty hardcore right and
hardcore [ __ ] Lyndon returned to Lin and
in 1949 joined the local branch of a
Trotskyist organization the Socialist
Workers Party okay so he comes home he's
in now he's just full-on in to socialism
he's diving in yeah he started using the
pseudonym Lin
market
Lynn Marcus yes sir he's just changed
his name okay herm I'll come home he
said it was based on his army nickname
Marco Polo his army nickname is Marco
Polo apparently was that just during
pool time uh you know I did see some
kids the other day playing with Marco
Polo in the park and one would just
close their eyes and the other one other
ones would run around yeah so you play
Marco Polo but waking a fool oh just the
outside of a pool that's all future
we're gonna live in whatever I don't
know if that's a great army nickname
it's probably not a great army nickname
because it kind of means like you can't
see anybody you don't know what you're
doing yeah okay
anyway Lennon got a job at a local
general electric plant to recruit
workers to the cause okay so when I see
54 and that's just casually kind of
bringing it up at you know like on a
coffee break during a fat shoe yeah and
like man oh man I think we all deserve a
little bit more or everything yeah don't
you think the workers should control the
factory what I'm just eating ruffles
yeah we're all just eating ruffles but
it would be pretty fun to have a
permanent revolution wouldn't it and I'm
not just talking in the factory I'm
talking worldwide what if the world was
the factory hmm I love this sour cream
and cheddar kind so so that was the
Socialist Workers Party things they
would try to get you jobs at factories a
name where you would try to write your
trading the workers right in 1954 he
married Lynn who was a fellow swp member
wait sorry he what he's sorry
his name is originally Lyndon he moved
to Lynn he changes his name to Lynn and
he's marrying Lynn well her name is
actually Janice Neuberger but she
changed it to Lynn so just everybody
slowly becoming Lynn's lot of Lynn's
going I mean this is yeah I mean look
there wasn't a lot of creativity
happening there's none I mean they're
like what should we call it what city do
we live in we'll both be Lynn hey Lynn
yeah then we shouldn't
so not you sorry the lid next to you I
was talking about the city huh I was
talking about the city oh well now I've
got to lens over here and I'm a Lin what
did you want Lin say something about me
no not you Lin sorry we're trying to
form a full lens here again as we're
casting we're just trying to go to Lin
where was she named the Workers Union
Lind what does it stand for
local when 142 Lin oh it's catchy yeah
hi Lin
just say something about Lin white hi
Lin hi I'm also Lin hey bro
rourou he said his name's land who talks
dog
who's that person that's me I'm on LSD
so he gets married they moved to New
York City where the Socialist Worker
Party headquarters were Lyndon read a
lot much Lin Lyndon okay Linda I'm not
gonna calm Lin I'm gonna calm Lyndon
just thank you black yeah for a cohesion
when people keep changing their names
we'll just stick with the birth name
okay so he read a lot about cybernetics
and computing and then became convinced
trust Trotskyists weren't thinking big
enough about transformations of the
world okay so the people who were
looking to transform the world the
people who were looking for a world
revolution are not thinking big enough
they are too tiny of thinkers yes he
what is what's bigger a universal
workers for underwater life that's right
we have to also underwater he wrote for
socialist publications and started a
management consulting company okay which
advised managers how to control workers
in reduced labor cost okay to control
workers and reduce Lee but why wait this
is the problems guy is does he can he
pick a spot and stay in it so he do you
mean he's on he's he's gone from now
being he communist no he's still doing
that at night yes okay so also he's
still doing it his his daylighting
as someone who's working a
his cause so hear me out so he's a he's
a trotsky's he's trying to organize
workers to essentially have a worldwide
revolution where the workers are in
charge yes the workers run things and
then but he's got to make money right so
he starts a management business that he
know what he knows really well is how
workers organized so he now can use that
information to make some cash on the
side of telling managers how to control
workers and then he can use that money
you can put that money back into his
Communist Party right so it's you see
how it works yes like a dietician who's
a competitive eater that's correct right
okay so limit also now began to fancy
himself as a physics expert I've done
that because he's done so much reading
and once you've read enough you're like
yeah that's how physics works and most
things yeah doctors everything hmm
during 140 our writing binge with no
food or sleep he quote he went on a
40-hour this guy's okay now I'm 100%
this guy's insane I was pretty sure this
man's crazy
what are you talking about he's just
right for 40 hours he's an idea man
that's methy he quote saw clearly for
the first time the nature of the
solution to the particle field paradox
oh he's the guy huh yeah and this is the
guy who did it the particle field
paradox and its solution were both
invented by Lyndon LaRouche wait so he
he this guy he finally solved the
solution he got the solution he found a
few of the particle field paradox which
is something that he came up with he
made up right that's easy to do yeah I
finally answered the age-old question I
asked last week around this time he also
began holding a psychoanalytic
counseling sessions oh here we go
one client was a former freedom rider
who committed suicide linden claimed it
was due to a savage remark made by
Janice who's Janice his wife Lynn Oh
Lynn Lynn - okay London linden a quote
he so he was during a psychoanalyzing
session this
kills himself I was like Janice not
during no but like later it was one of
subsequently client slash patients sure
they killed himself and he's like Janet
her eyes he said it quote killed my last
strong feeling for the marriage and in
1963 they separated Linville in rough
yeah
in 1964 Lyndon move in with another
social worker party member Carol a snit
sir they never married and she but she
still became Carol Lewis so I don't
really understand how that works but she
changed her name this guy's taken the
rulebook and tossed it and now let's
remember he's still going by Lynn Marcus
yes he's Lynn Marcus and now he's
married to cut Carol LaRouche who took
his I guess what I'd call his maiden
name so problems started to arise in the
Socialist Worker party factional
disputes in 1966 Lyndon and Carol left
the Socialist Workers Party okay and in
1967 Lyndon started teaching Marxism
classes at the Free School of New York
he started to recruit followers he was
pulling away from the Stalinist
progressive Labour Party okay so this is
this is very like these are factions
yeah the classes also attracted students
from Columbia University and Lyndon
became involved with the Columbia
chapter of students for a Democratic
Society which is a company country wide
campus organization okay and in 1968 the
SDS occupied Columbia to protest Vietnam
big news all across the country minions
involved in that he helped organized by
the scenes and as follows to followers a
major part of the action right but like
the Socialist Worker a party the the
students for a Democratic Society also
start splintering in a faction right
it's just it's just the left this is the
left us rings a minor Bell one was loyal
to linen that group became the National
caucus of Labor Committee
the NCL see okay
so that's his now this is his
organization okay and CL say okay the
NCL see expanded and became a prominent
national Marxist organization okay it
published a major leftist newspaper and
new solidarity in 1971 it formed a
political party the US Labor Party okay
they had an intense rivalry with the
Communist Party USA okay and CLC members
disrupted communist meetings the
Communist Party in turn claimed the N
CLC was being secretly run by government
agents which you would think like if
there's another leftist organization
that is coming and [ __ ] up your
meetings in your combination they have
to be right there's no way that somebody
who believes as closely to I is going to
do something to blow this all up that's
right right to throw a a little flavour
into the mix Lyndon then became obsessed
with European fascism here it is
may as well be a boat horn in the
distance it's coming here it is here it
is in 1971 he wrote an article
predicting a fascist movement would soon
rise in America oh dear oh no he said
the movement we use Jews as scapegoats
and it's capitalist leaders would use
quote advanced brainwashing techniques
to create quote left proto-fascist
zombies oh my god dave is left
proto-fascist zombies but advanced
brainwashing techniques is not what I
mean that's not really realistic let's
be honest advanced brainwashing
techniques yeah what is that I mean I
would think we live in a time of
adventure he somehow had managed to be
an accepted part of the left in America
and was being invited to speak on
college campuses so he's you know he's
out there he's part of the left movement
still and he's talking all over the
place and giving us ideas right and I
did 71 he even debated debated respected
a communist abba lerner Lyndon then
began purging independent minded members
from the N CLC and smart that's how you
grow that's
and doing this he became surrounded by
unquestioning loyal supporters hmm
that's what you want that's yep much
like his dad's hero Hitler in January
1973 the NSC LC had 600 members in 25
chapters okay a couple in Europe and
then Carol left Linden and moved to
England with a another male and CLC
member so she's okay right a new faction
yes she's fine
some hot sex from a younger guy I think
we can pretty much yeah that's pretty
right yeah no we get it she left with a
guy and she's like let's do this near
the tames she's nice dude this near the
tames that's not a quote can we just
listen she said this we understand she
founded another's lover and I gotta [ __ ]
you under par okay
all right all right no I die personally
know the place listen don't I think we
get it she went to England with a guy
yep I want to stop no we went she went
to England okay we don't need any more
actual specifics of what she knocks at
you from behind and I look at the
Gherkin at the Gherkin two building in
London is it yeah get some [ __ ]
culture getting the Gherkin in front and
him back let's keep it clean you son of
a [ __ ] you led me there so now this now
this Carolyn and the other the dude left
right after the NCL cease rivalry with
the Communist Party USA intensified by
today Linden
started ordering the N CLC's most
athletic members to undergo street
fighter training this is quite a turn
with clubs pipes and nunchucks yeah
nunchucks just like you find behind a
dumpster just a street fight they're all
over the place for sure yeah it is the
70s so there is a lot of nunchucks it's
probably the peak of nunchucks on the
street in April the Communist Party
picketed an NC LC conference with signs
comparing the NCL C to the Ku Klux Klan
okay we're not great knife right if
memory serves an abysmal organization
the NCL C held
Oh God
the NCAA held a meeting at which Linden
vowed to quote mop the CP up in two
months mop okay yeah and that became
opera that began operation mop up oh
dear Lord
operation mop up yeah Wow
he's like Mickey from Rocky he's yeah
they were like a general he's going to
he's good it's a war they're declaring
war against the fighting pipe none
chucking war that's right
classic left stuff it's the very very
lefty so the NCL sea battalions would
storm leftist bookstores and beat anyone
up who tried to stop them which included
the use of nunchucks so they're he's
just because none shot because the
bookstores are all affiliated with a
party right it's a Barnes & Noble and
someone came in with nunchucks and just
began beating people okay first of all
it's not Barnes & Noble because Barnes &
Noble isn't like run by some socialist
guy it's it's like a it's like an
affiliated bookstore so they're saying
yeah we're they're like read just like
you just read and you just read nearly
I'm gonna read a little bit about Stalin
right now and then deeds comes through
the door with a nunchucks right and you
even have a little skull fracture well
yeah because that's your own fault for
being in the wrong bookstore and trying
to stop them that just my favorite line
in the sand don't try to stop them from
beating you or you'll get beaten that's
right yeah okay
so in Detroit a partially paralyzed
activist was savagely beat 30 NC LC
attackers in Philadelphia raided a
leftist meeting a witness said quote the
stairs were a mass of blood so they're
[ __ ] yeah they're they're rollin yep
new solitary ran overtly racist articles
boy this is really it's just it's been a
subtle u-turn
crazy way to get here I mean this all
started very simple we've definitely
taken some turns yes in Buffalo and all
white and CLC gang terrorized a Martin
Luther King Society meeting going in and
assaulting black members what what is
like how did how do you get there from
where he just was I mean now it's just
the expansion of believing that your
party is exclusive and better than
everything else well going through this
it's hard to do it in a linear fashion
this was one where there was just yeah
constantly [ __ ] shifting and moving but
he's he started to have some
relationships with some KKK people so
there was a reason that they accused him
of right right so there was at that
Martin Luther King Society meeting there
was a noticeable lack of police response
can you imagine a bunch of white people
beating a bunch of black people and not
being a police response can you imagine
that in America yeah
yes I'd this led to a belief that law
enforcement supported operation mop up
weird so weird
there is evidence the FBI sent anonymous
pamphlets to fan the flame wait and
weirder and promote the leftist
infighting Dave what yeah operation mop
up involved at least 60 attacks
no one was critically injured but
several people were hospitalized okay
then in the middle of this insane war
that he started Lyndon just declared
victory and called the war over that's
how you do it hey we did it boys how you
do it mopped up a racket
we did everything we came here to do we
got the oil everything's gonna be fine
now it's done from here on out the NCL
see immediately left the Communist Party
long so that was it they just all summer
like I we did it we did our thing okay
many believe the real goal was to weed
out on
and CLC members and deepen the
commitment of remaining members oh so it
was like who will fight for me yes it is
and people stepped up yes Fight Club the
cult that's right
if I could the cult so he got me now I
got even deeper into his psychoanalysis
oh good good good good and the group at
this point was definitely a cult yeah I
mean every step of the way it's only
gotten stronger and stronger yeah he's
always been he's been the whole thing's
been weeding but this now is now now
you're okay so you've worked on the
physical now let's get inside of your
head that's right he told his members he
would quote make you organisers by
taking your bedrooms away from you I
shall expose you to the cruel fact of
your impotence I will to take away from
you all you all hope that you can flee
the terrors of politics to the safety of
the personal life so he's saying I mean
without question I'd be like I'm leaving
now officially bad you say that but
you'd also be like I've got two hours
sleep and this sounds awesome yeah and I
beat a guy with a nunchuck so I'm in
yeah all right take away our beds many
of the members lived in an apartment
block and they're healed meetings where
he encouraged the group to heap a
vicious verbal attacks on a soul member
okay when the person broke down and
started sobbing hysterically Lyndon
called it a sign of psychic liberation
and he named it says so culty he named
it ego stripping uh we believe heard
this in a million I know but it's still
[ __ ] it's horrible when it like starts
yeah but it's always the same thing they
all do this yeah by the way how
over/under right now until he starts
having sex with people in the cult I'm
gonna say you know what I always I those
are the ones I the cult stories I avoid
that's why we don't do very many cult
stories because they all usually end up
with a guy being like I look I'm gonna
[ __ ] your daughter you can't have sex
nobody else could have sex I have sex
with everybody yeah and then he starts
having sex with women he said by the way
I should also probably start having sex
with your daughter right
every call that's like every kind yeah
so I know this is an odd [ __ ] call is
it on [ __ ] cult which is the rare
I'll put my shirt back on
when I'm gonna take mine off okay no
when the person yeah so the person
breaks down sir sobbing hysterically
it's called LIGO stripping and he called
it quote an act of social love right
this is what you do when you verbally
destroy another human sure yeah but
during sessions he called himself
they're a sure linker German for the
abominable one oh my god this is not
good this is an act of social love from
the obatala walk the abominable one yeah
I'm - licker the abominable one and and
CLC member X and CLC member describe it
as quote pure psychological terror that
transformed us into sniveling informers
vying with each other for Linden's
approval now Lyndon told his followers
he was being targeted for assassination
by different villains of course the
Joker KGB international drug traffickers
Henry Kissinger FBI the Ayatollah
Khomeini oh my god new home our could
office this list okay so what's the plan
well of the world like I mean look those
are a lot of there's a lot of sneaky
dudes in there yeah it's a bad list to
have as a bad list of people who wanna
kill you if all those people want to
kill you you will be particularly Henry
Kissinger Henry Kissinger wants you dead
you almost died instantly when a puddle
with blinking eyeballs can kill you you
know it's dangerous I was kissing you're
still alive he's not at this point he's
like clay that needs to get shaped again
God exactly Henry yeah
he warned followers that if they let the
CIA kidnap and torture them quote it's
not the pain that brain Washington's
people what kills you is when you eat
excrement as a mother but yep yep yep
this is what he warns his followers that
if they let if they let the CIA kidnap
and torture them let is there
quote it's not the pain that brainwashes
people what kills you is when you eat
excrement as a way of inducing your
torturer to lay off the pain oh my god
what what he so in his world the CIA has
you in a room and they're just beating
you until you eat [ __ ] mm-hmm well you
he's saying you eat your own [ __ ] Oh as
a way of letting them know that you've
lost your mind and are they the ones
putting you up to this or you just
eventually like I haven't proven it I
think you're getting hello I think
you're getting tortured so much I went
there at some point you're like hard I'm
gonna eat my poop now guard guard I have
an update
I'm officially broken look at what I've
eaten there's a lot of fecal play in
prison well you're just talking about
the musical right yeah okay he then
wrote a new solidarity editorial titled
will you eat [ __ ] for Rockefeller this
is gonna take a little further down the
street then is it so he's fallen in love
with something that he said he's like I
really think there's a future yeah
there's maybe the CIA makes you eat poo
right I'm on to something with the
[ __ ] stuff I know I am and then you
know what happens they're gonna make eat
poo again I mean I studied physics sorry
I'm actually the guy who solved that
problem I created a shooting problem
yeah I found a yeah like they say in
science find a hole and fill it [ __ ] so
then Lennon said a German and CLC member
was brainwashed by a KGB CIA team which
is pretty common for this to know those
well I'm not I mean I laugh but those
two were together a ton like people
think they were investigating each other
they were forming the cij KGB that's
right yeah
and given orders to assassinate him
mm-hmm when they're working in
conjunction you are an enemy urine yeah
then of course they want to take down
some crazy cult leader yeah but Lyndon
foiled applauded by recognizing the
symptoms of brainwashing and deep
programming the assassin mm-hmm using
techniques quote absolutely
unprecedented in a psychological science
Dave let's go to the video we don't have
video evidence of this
that's interesting so he's just sort of
it's hearsay yeah interesting yeah it's
very much the definition of he's just
like hey this thing happened well and I
use you guys we're eating lunch I've
gotten too crazy update I just got a man
from the CIA to eat his poop I'm [ __ ]
crazy good at this all right Lyndon
wrote internal and CLC documents draw in
an internal and clz document in August
quote rats see them approaching see
their beady eyes so many beady eyes all
looking at us ugh it seems almost that
rats have hands
CIA rats KGB rats FBI rats trade union
official rats left rats generally rats
rats rats be impotent the rats hate
anything which is not impotent there are
so many rats gigantic awfully monstrous
beetles malevolent beetles with pedia
beetle eyes and gigantic sexual organs
are coming to rape us oh man anyway
enjoy your breakfast go anyways all
right enough Alex Jones for everyone wow
so that's kind of right right getting a
little crazy Wow yeah I'm starting to
feel uncomfortable he's just get into
rat stuff boy oh boy
Linda began to write a lot more would be
great if someone had to like if that was
a dictation Andrea come in here I've got
a note I want to give you rats rats rats
they're all coming beady little eyes
rats the lot of them rats rats rats yeah
I hate the Beatles the band yep
especially John he's a rat in his own
poo CIA made him rats rats rats rats
rats rats rats rats rats rats beetles
rats poo ate John signed Linden Lyn her
Mile Carol from Lynn the second
Jr would you read that back to me you
seem like you're really into scat like
it's repetitive no it's just what that's
the prison they've they've put us in we
have no choice but to fight okay so I'm
gonna just drop this and scream and
Ronald okay yep ready Linda began to
write a lot more one example is a twenty
six thousand word piece that's a lot
called quote the sexual impotence of the
Puerto Rican Socialist Party oh sweet
God
this is just like hard to even like this
guy's we think harder harder to mock
because like this is genuinely horrible
yeah let the the Puerto Rican socialist
can't [ __ ] that's my I'm gonna change
the title but right now it's the Puerto
Rican socialist camp FARC so that that
would that like covered everything from
Hegel to the agony of self-consciousness
to racial racist ramblings on Latin
American macho culture and and these
kind of these kind of writings become
his thing like it's just for happening
all the time he's just they're sort of
just rants about whatever a crazy man is
thinking sure
we call it Twitter yes so Carole member
Cara yeah that's who went to college not
married yep she was banging the guy at
the Gherkin so he returns the guy yeah
the guy girl stays the carol was bangin
he comes back to New York alone I don't
know if it's with a with her without her
didn't didn't find that out so Linden
decided that this guy had been
brainwashed when he came back any d
programs okay and then he said the
boyfriend had been tortured by the CIA
and mi6 and given a trigger word and
once he heard that trigger word he would
kill Carol
so he's did he write The Naked Gun
because that
and he would I'm not sure when the
manchurian Kennedy came out oh right it
was way before this so yeah this is
clearly just taken from the right 62
yeah so he just took it from me
I hate Lyndon I know I love you're right
but I remember seeing this in a movie um
yeah why Frank it's a Frank Sinatra The
Manchurian Candidate sounds pretty close
nope it's a movie yeah it's a nope not
ringing any bells but this is different
this is basically what we're just gonna
take somebody and manipulate them to the
point that you know they are able to do
the bidding of the system and that's
what we're fighting against know sort of
Mandarin Candidate or whatever you're
talking about so yeah there's none of
that and I don't even think that's a
movie has anyone even heard of that
movie yeah exactly nobody's heard of it
except for those hands that went up so
nobody's heard of it everybody raised
nobody's heard of it it was a movie
night here we did that on the movie
night here all right here it is cats out
of the bag I wrote The Manchurian
Candidate there we go oh my god yeah
mazing but I wrote it based on this
situation and I went back in time and
wrote it then Wow so I just have placed
that in you guys this week where there
were it's a rat were there rats and
g-man [ __ ] I'm not like I know what you
guys are after you want a rat ranch
you're not gonna milk what automated I
know that ran that read write read write
read their beady little eyes are coming
down the street so right so he deep
programs this guy and and also the the
boyfriend
one of the other things he'd been
brainwashed to do was to convince Cubans
in the USA to assassinate Linden sure
quite a list of people trying to kill
this guy yeah I mean it's it's a long
lens job stuff yeah
Linden quote any of you who say this is
a hoax your cruds your subhuman you're
not serious the human race is
steak either we win or there is no
humanity it is very Alex Jonesy yeah
the boyfriend wrote Flyers about his
brainwashing and then those were passed
out in the cities in cities okay the NS
ELC sent tapes of of his deprogramming
to the New York Times sure so audio
tapes of when he was D programmed by
Lyndon finally The Times article which
is written on this quote there are
sounds of weeping and vomiting oh my god
quite a start and mr. white complains of
being deprived of sleep of food and
cigarettes
I'd want quite a list for that kind of a
complaining - I need the basics water
food marburo at one point someone says
raise the voltage but LaRouche says this
was associated with the bright lights
used in the questioning rather than an
electric shock well but I to be fair you
know how it is when like you want
someone to turn the lights on yeah you
just like hit the voltage back but
that's how he we say so it had to be
about the light just imagine being so
crazy that you torture a guy and then
send that as a tape to the New York
Times yeah look we found out this
information
he's just puking and whining and you're
like what do you think huh
not easy people say I have it easy I
don't I do not you heard what I had to
put that man through I turned those
lights on real bright at him any else
see any sense ELC members who were
skeptical Lyndon accused of being in on
the plot well then it's time to leave
because otherwise he's gonna deprogram
you
maybe I don't want that no in January
1974 a member wrote a note saying she
was being held prisoner and forced to
listen to Beethoven at a high volume
okay what so he is just legal is he I
mean is the Clockwork Orange
he's just lifting plots this is also us
cytology thing okay great help people
prisoner and loud music and stuff she
made it so she wrote this note and she
and she folds into a paper airplane and
throws it out the window
Oh God and someone gets it oh my god
you're finding that whatever this is
about
say imagine what says oh my god where
what the hell
police came and they were greeted by n
CLC members who said they were staying
with her because she'd been brainwashed
to kill Linda you don't understand we've
got to turn the voltage up and they were
like okay well that's we know what you
guys are gonna do put her in a Cell make
her eat her poo No thank you very much
Peter
by early 1974 anyone who questioned
Lyndon was out of the NCL sea okay by
mid 1974 Lyndon made connections with
the Ku Klux Klan and neo-nazis great so
we are finally we finally arrived at our
destination where we wanted to be always
Lyndon and n CLC members met with clan
leaders in neo-nazis in 1975 Lyndon said
the real enemy was the nan and CLC left
and the NCL C should quote cooperate
with the right to defeat this common
enemy oh my god right yeah I mean look
if you have an enemy so in 1976 now
going by Lyndon LaRouche okay so now
he's changed his name back from Lynn
Marcus all right he ran as the UCL P's
presidential nominees that's the party
he made way back when than we talked
about okay so he's now finally running
for president and they've they've
already run a bunch of candidates around
the country and you know smaller races
right and a third party hated races Hey
we're killing it in here at a third
party debate Lyndon said if Carter won
there would quickly be a global
financial collapse followed by a nuclear
war this is in a debate mm-hmm and he
said we had a fight Jimmy well I don't
believe he has any factual information
to back that up
he won 40,000 primary votes they had 140
us Opie candidates in 21 states and they
won more nationwide votes than any
left-wing third party Wow and more votes
than all but one right wing third party
Wow
lenin went to a conference an appetite
there is people want this kind of great
information they want to hear something
new yeah interesting yeah Linda went to
a conference in Germany in 1977 in an MC
I was just about to say get this guy to
Germany hurry and there he met Helga zap
when he returned is this person animated
yes she is a cartoon character when he
returned he called Jews a quote subhuman
oligarchical species and claimed a
Jewish conspiracies and customs yes sir
were just asking how long were there and
he claimed a Jewish conspiracy had put
Hitler into power and brainwashed Nazis
into their atrocities wow that is quite
a theory really that is really it really
doesn't hold up it would be like we're
gonna play a game called how do you
offend Jewish people about the Holocaust
the most really the way you guys did it
you came up with Hitler wait what uh-huh
it's the worst idea I think II not
sneaky nice try the worst idea I know
we've got proof a ton of proof mm-hmm
look at this you have no proof well
still look at the palm of my hand yeah
that's my love line okay I gotta go it
stops here so I'll probably married
again good to meet you
he also started using British as a code
word for Jewish Oh God that's that means
your that means you're saying bad things
for example he claimed Israel the
Rothschilds and quote other British
families were planning a new Holocaust
we all know yep bingo
buying a new Holocaust 100 times worse
than Hitler's Wow in December he married
Helga she was 55 he was 29 that can't be
right well he was 55 she was 29 okay I
by the way how amazing is it that we
live in a world where that first one was
like what and this new one is like right
okay gotcha yes finally yes and Linden
was now openly fascist well you know
that's the title of the movie it's a
hell of an openly fascist hell of a trip
yeah yeah quotas not necessary
to where swastika to be a fascist it is
not necessary to call oneself a fascist
to be a fascist
it is simply necessary to be one it's a
pretty strong take dumb quote Lenin now
solidified what he called the grand
design which became the driving force
behind his expanding Network they
they're now known as the LaRouche Ian's
that name is it's not great it's also
there's also a lot of this wherever they
go how do you spell that
yeah right two words is the are
capitalized yeah the are capitalized
okay and they a is big too or it's a
little a little I'm not fine you guys in
here hi you guys have a table at this
yes big a little little yeah have a big
girl big are a big are oh you were
HIA NS hyphenated know I've been
hyphenating it yeah and these there's
two words yeah well I guess that makes
it one more okay we should have gone
with the linens that is catchy or the
Lynn the Linds
easy easy to find the plan was for
America this is the grand design right
and then the world to defeat the
centuries-old jewish cabal and become a
totalitarian dictatorship rule based
small elite of golden souls who had
mastered Linden's philosophies mm-hmm
just normal stuff
great so basically just a few people a
few of the chosen 's live here you want
to get rid of the Jewish people and
replace it with a small cabal of
lunatics right right like a small yes
people who weren't golden souls would
become soldiers citizens with no freedom
great now that is that's also a fun
cells there's a golden soul or you can
be one of these foot soldiers yeah it's
a slave soldier based great yeah I know
schools would teach linens ideas which
would lead to unprecedented technology
technological leaps by the way the whole
time you've been talking I've just been
thinking this guy has an eye towards the
future of Technology he sees he's is
like Silicon Valley in his brain bingo
the Russians began fundraising in
airports and crowded businesses their
goal was to get large loans for research
they told people they're gonna get those
at airports yes that's all you're gonna
get your hundred
you know they stop that but that was a
thing for a long time I only know that
because of watching the movie airplane
of course that's how most people know
but right it must yeah so what just like
tons and tons of people asking for yeah
well this was before this is when you
could just go to the gate right so there
was no security so you I don't know like
about this I'm gonna feel sick about how
easy it was to get on a plane yeah those
were the days when you're just like hey
I have a ticket yeah cuz now we need a
some group to go through that doesn't
actually do anything yeah except take
your water so you have to buy more
shampoo it's weird it's almost like
they've made billions of dollars selling
water on the other side of those uh yeah
you know mmm Lucian's began fundraising
at airports and crowded businesses their
goal was to get large loans for research
they told people they would get huge
returns uh-huh throughout there they
start taking advantage of senior
citizens who are taking the bait and
loans were rarely repaid the fund
raisers would bring in 200 million over
the years Wow machines ran various
businesses one a computer programming
company had clients including Citibank
Mobil Oil and AT&T
good all good companies so always
happens with these groups they they
start you know pooling the money from
all the the cult members I got my red
about one guy and he he was like married
and then he got into the NCAA LC and
then he left his wife and then he he
gave all their money to the cult and
then and then they had to give like $20
a month to linden which was a pretty
decent amount at the time and so he they
would just all go on unemployment or
welfare and just give the money to him
that's cool yeah so it's a cool chill
system yeah so he's just basically
raking in money and then nestle it
eventually he needs more money yes so
now he's getting corporate infusion and
then you also go after like a guy who
owns a company and you get him into the
cult you know it's all that right good
stuff yeah
Leonard gain influence through the NCL
C's worldwide intelligence gathering
apparatus okay what is I'm picturing a
robot with no wires so a member of
Reagan's National Security Council said
it was quote one of the best private
intelligence services in the world
slaves which was so the NCL c-- has
created an intelligence gathering group
and now the reagan is saying that they
are the best intelligence gatherers in
the world one of the best Wow NC LC
higher-ups we're now being invited to
sit in on NSC meetings oh my god so they
make connections with Reagan David
convinced the Reagan people that they
were smart and gathering intelligence
yeah that was important and now they're
literally sitting in on at NSC meetings
could you imagine a an administration
where crazy people sit on NSC meetings
no it's someday that'll happen maybe UNC
LC agents impersonated media and
exaggerated linens credentials they
strategically pick sides in
international disputes and and dozens of
governments then paid them to gather
intelligence so they would like the take
the rich softwood in England the
Falklands England and and Argentina and
then they would go okay so England on
this one and then they would giving them
the information they wanted and get
money and write the NCL see published a
periodical executive Intelligence Review
and it ran a lot of bad Intel this was
partly due to Roy Franken Hauser the
Grand Dragon of the Pennsylvania KKK who
befriended Lyndon in 1970 not Jesus
Christ Roy said he was a messenger for a
mysterious intelligence operative named
codenamed mister edy
what he made he just made that up that's
it mister edy
well the source is a source of course of
course and no one could talk to a source
of course that is of course unless the
stars
mr. ed would pass messages to the hi Eve
how am I gonna do anything but your
horse doing this I couldn't either I
mean it's the most [ __ ] up thing ever
I've got something from downtown what is
it mr. mr. ed passed messages to the
highest levels of the CIA in White House
and was always telling Roy about wild
plots against Linden's life okay
so right so this is mysterious character
who's got all these connections lawyer
he's also keeps telling Linden which
Linden already says but now he's just
getting it reaffirmed right Linden said
Roy could quote detect nasties by their
wiggle Oh which we all I mean the basket
today yeah for sure
but mr. ed did not exist Roy made him up
interesting most of the intelligence was
made up by Roy and Rory even had a
friend pretend he was mr. Edie and go to
meetings with Lyndon oh that guy dude
what if you know it just shut up just
sit or not he's [ __ ] crazy
just look not into it in 1980 Lyndon ran
for president again his platform
included building a tunnel under the
Bering Strait his own version of quantum
physics and making his wedding
anniversary a week-long national holiday
he dissolved the US LP and ran as a
Democrat oh my god this guy well he
thought there's not a conservative wing
of the Democratic Party so write that
boy right the DNC couldn't legally ban
him from entering primaries so Lyndon
ran a national half-hour TV ads
describing himself as similar to FDR oh
wow and his name recognition shot up
People magazine said he had the quote
best organized fringe campaign in
American history he went 185 thousand
votes in 15 states now he's getting
matching funding so when you write him
out you can get matching funding so he's
getting money like this is all totally
doable financially
right in the early 1980s Lyndon focused
on his scientific organization so he's a
scientific organization called the
fusion Energi foundation on a
space-based beam weapon but the fef
recruited respected scientists and was
praised by a government physicist for
its quote top-drawer technical expertise
the fef lobbied and met with Reagan
administration top officials about the
space-based beam weapons problem so this
they met with Ronald Reagan's
administration about making a space beam
you're about to say yes yeah what that's
[ __ ] crazy
in 1983 February 1983 Lyndon wrote that
beams weapons would become quote a
household word in America during the
month of March what ok
in March Ronald Reagan announced the
Strategic Defense Initiative aka Star
Wars a space-based beam weapons program
[Applause]
dammit what happened it's just
impossible we need the beam weapon the
fef became the de facto Star Wars
spokespeople and were often quoted in
the media as respected space beam
weapons experts well that is an
oxymoronic title like here are the race
to space beam experts people want to act
like Trump is this unique thing yeah we
[ __ ] been here before yeah and it's
just that nobody everyone acts like it
didn't know we've been here yeah
volusion's moved to a compound in rural
Leesburg Virginia an hour outside of DC
because quote the terrorist organization
organizations which have targeted mr.
LaRouche do not have bases of operations
of Virginia a cult member later said
Linda was just isolating supporters to
make them quote totally creatures of the
organization the compound was guarded by
in camouflage with automatic weapons the
Russians
Lucien's focused their support on
Reagan's 1984 election they recruited
2,000 candidates to run in primaries
nationwide but they weren't actually
running their whole goal is to just
smear Democratic candidate Walter
Mondale hmm so on every all these 2000
races around the country you just have a
Republican a Democrat and then versus or
or it's personal Democrat is often just
talking [ __ ] about run on presidential
candidate right right
most had no connection to Lyndon and
we're just confused senior citizens or
ultra-conservatives trying to help
Reagan well that sounds like the
Democrats despite running as Democrats
they praised Reagan and Star Wars well
savagely attacking Mondale in 1984 NBC
reporter Pat Lynch ran an expose about
lure she ins ties to the Reagan
administration particularly the National
Security Council in it the
anti-defamation league called Lyndon an
anti-semite and LaRouche ian's then
picketed NBC was signs reading Lynch Pat
Lynch and posters and posted flyers in
Lynch's parents neighborhood claiming
she was running a call-girl ring out of
their home
see this is how and this is still going
on today this right wing tactic of if
you say anything about us are are
attacks on you will be vicious to the
point it's pure intimidation and it
works yeah
Lyndon sued NBC and the anti-defamation
league for defamation oh my god that is
so amazing that is amazing for what
information should have seen this coming
no word the anti-defamation league yeah
well you defamed us nice try liars Linda
was extensively questioned in the
courtroom a juror quote all of us had
sores on the inside of our cheeks either
from biting them to keep from laughing
or to keep from screaming
Jesus Christ Linda lost the case and he
paid three million to NBC for directing
supporters to impersonate Lynch and her
staff this is crazy
and yet the Reagan administration
refused to speak out against Lyndon
LaRouche LaRouche ian's picked up
fundraising for Reagan asking elderly
conservatives to hand over their life
savings to quote help President Reagan
keep America strong in 1986
Ellucian candidates won Democratic
nominations for lieutenant governor and
secory Secretary of State in Illinois
now there's a tons of corruption in
Chicago and everyone gets mad at it so
no one was expecting it because they
weren't following election return so the
Lucien's don't think anything's gonna
happen they're not following election
returns so at the time that the election
results are coming in the Lucien's are
holding a mock exorcism outside of the
house of a professor the lieutenant
governor who they said was a evil
warlock I'm trying to fix this warlock
what's going on you guys you're the
lieutenant governor now I have it
there's a demon in this are you serious
you want what well that is just they
just won the Democratic primary oh the
primary okay but still it [ __ ]
everything in her victory speech the
LaRue she and Secretary of State nominee
said quote I'm going to revive the
spirit of Abraham Lincoln and General
Patton we're gonna roll our tanks down
State Street here we go
a lot of Dems had cast protest votes
against the corrupt Democratic machine
but LaRouche ian's campaigned vigorously
to get white working-class voters with
their anti dragon anti-crime platform an
Illinois pollster said quote this wasn't
a fluke they seized an opportunity still
the lure she lost in the general
election but he caused the dam to lose -
which was the goal well then the
Democratic Party's goal was for the
Lucien's to lose that's right fell to
[ __ ] show a couple of months later the
Secretary of State nominee threw a pound
of raw liver at the feet of the
Milwaukee Archbishop for supporting the
International Monetary Fund Wow
in California linen created the prevent
AIDS now initiative committee I have a
feeling it's not going to be the way
that we would all hope to prevent
prevent AIDS now initiative committee he
spells out panic okay it was to promote
his belief that AIDS was they quote
manmade evil linked to cults out of
Babylon
he said aids could be spread by air rats
and mosquitoes I mean I was in
California this time I remember this it
was un-fuckin'-believable right using
the slogan quote spread panic not AIDS
LaRue Sheehan gathered 700 thousand
signatures to get proposition 64 on the
1986 ballot which called for the
quarantine of AIDS patients Wow yeah
their AIDS propaganda was identical to
Nazi syphilis propaganda prop 64 got
over 2 million votes 29% of the total
Wow
that's too much yeah so it's still a win
for Lyndon his biography later wrote
quote LaRouche scored a major
ideological breakthrough for neo Nazism
in America he took a previously taboo
idea enforced isolation for the
scapegoat and elevated it to a topic of
legitimate discourse imagine that
happening yeah can't imagine but Linda's
financial empire was unraveling a grand
jury in Boston indicted a LaRue Chien
organization on credit-card fraud and
Lyndon asked Roy Frank Houser to send
mr. Edie to investigate yeah well you
know we got a call who
miss dread yes yeah yeah well here's the
thing he is now teaching scuba lessons
he's a he's a horse he's a horse what
ever seen the show mr. head yeah it's
that guy what are you talking about he's
the guy I had meetings with this guy
he's oh that guy that's I um no CIA that
guy that guy yeah he teaches scuba now
he's a scuba team he's the horse the
horse you know
he's the horse he's a horse of course so
he sends Roy gives me joy you know money
to investigate with mr. ed but Roy
instead went to a Star Trek convention
in Scranton hey how's the investigation
going really good put your phaser not
now it's really good we're actually
knee-deep in this right now god I'll
tell you it mr. ed is he's a pit bull
when you get him out here put me
straight on the phone that is he's the
guy that is not gonna be possible right
now well he is with Spock he called
linen from the convention and warned him
that the FBI had wiretap lumen Linden's
phones so he just gave him like a little
bit of stuff to go crazy on yeah hey you
know but they did tap your phones well
that's the week so Roy
very soon after was arrested on a
variety of charges and he cooperated
with prosecutors and testified did he
give up mr. ed well he did talk about
mr. ed he testified the Lewises
organization asked him to assassinate
former US Secretary of State Henry
Kissinger among other things why didn't
that happen like why couldn't one good
thing come out of this like they kill
they kill Kissinger like so Lyndon was
called as a defense witness kill liquid
it's true
Lenin was called as a defense witness
for Roy but he used his Fifth Amendment
rights and didn't okay Roy was found
guilty of his obstructing justice for
Lyndon and it was sentenced to three
years in prison and then he was given
testimony I mean he was given immunity
to testify against Lyndon right okay
so he also during that trial explained
that mr. ed wasn't real oh man imagine
imagine Linda its face what he's hearing
that what Linda ran for president in
1988 the regime candidates one more
local Democratic primaries than ever but
a court found Lyndon guilty of 11 counts
of mail fraud and conspiring to defraud
the IRS On January 20th night so he
wasn't under audit that's right
January 28th 1989 linin got a 15-year
sentence and he was sent to you federal
prison in Minnesota
now Helga's in charge okay so Helga
turns all the lure Chien resources to
her passion project lowering the
standard International orchestral tuning
pitch by an imperceptible amount from
440 Hertz to 432 Hertz wait wait hold on
a minute now yeah okay the new goal is
to get the one more time the
International orchestral tuning pitch
the standard lower like 440 Hertz 824
essentially what that'll be set at I
really don't understand it well I think
it's just saying that well it's
basically saying like well it's at a
perceptible amount like it right yes yes
yes and an esoteric author had claimed
432 Hertz was the correct tuning for
cosmic potential unlocking x' and that
at 44 Hertz
it caused aggressive antisocial behavior
so that's the problem so we get this
right everything Cosmo songs peace on
earth right so the Russians got dozens
of operas biggest names including
Placido Domingo sane what and Luciano
Pavarotti to rot does he have any idea
what he's showing up to she's signed a
petition asking Italian parliament to
lower the national standard pitch he
signed it yeah
what they both did what how [ __ ] I don't
know man
but then the ties to the lower shins
were publicized and the campaign fell
apart okay Lyndon meanwhile in jail
claimed his cell was bugged and he ran
for president in 1992 well that's quite
it back to back he did not do well in
democratic primaries but ran on the
general election in states that allowed
imprisoned candidates sure he got the
second fewest votes nationally of any
candidate
being the last I really should not be in
politics that's all this is saying he
was released in January 1994 and yet in
the 1996 Democratic primaries he won
enough votes in Louisiana and Virginia
to get delegates at the National
Convention the party instructed states
to disregard his votes so no convention
voting delegates vote form
in 2000 he runs for president again and
he it's 22% of the vote in the Arkansas
Democratic primary this gave him six
delegates at the convention and the
National Party again refused to allow
his delegates and then came 9/11 and
Lyndon took a strong stand against the
Bush administration especially Dick
Cheney and with his huge opposition to
the Iraq war his this activism created a
big presence on college campuses and
brought him in many new young recruits
so it's a classic cult a member said
leaders quote were constantly asking us
if we would die for these ideas every
morning at 8:00 a.m. the followers at
the Virginia compound would sing old
slave spirituals followed by hearing
apocalyptic news briefing from Lyndon or
another leader and then they'd spread
the day spend the day fundraising and
recruiting until 10:00 p.m. in 1904
linear an for president at 2004
sorry 2004 you ran for president he told
his followers quote I have a better
chance of being elected than you have of
surviving if I'm not that's cool to hear
all right yeah do it or we're gonna die
can't you see Trump saying that yeah
yeah in 2008 and 2012 elections Lyndon
went after Obama calling him quote the
new Hitler which is weird cause he likes
Hitler but you know right yeah he called
climate change a hoax they disrupted
environmental rallies and they spent
2016 mocking Trump quote he's a
festering pustule on Satan's rump don't
you be a chump for Trump they would
chant that it rhymes a bunch but after
Trump won Lyndon praised Trump's quote
intent to end the policies of British
imperial free trade and making full
commitment to industry manufacturing
scientific advancement a World Peace
Roger stone spoke at a LaRouche
convention of course
and then Linda me I'm suffering from
dementia he sort of began he's
threatened posting YouTube videos they
were nonsensical like even more
nonsensical than they would be one
example quote we are about to do a job
on the study of China with the idea of
the development of the back of the moon
the back of the moon is very specific
kind of physical principle that
principle when properly understood will
change the history of mankind
on February 12th 9 2019 Lyndon LaRouche
died at the age of 96 when February 12th
Wow
2019 his followers refused to tell the
media and the location and the cause of
his death Wow Jesus Christ
how do you feel I don't know not good
but I do know I mean you know that like
you're right I think that everybody
treats Trump like an anomaly like how
did this happen and then there are there
are just so many little things that
happen here
yeah and and clearly there has been a
history of this sort of that's right
people act like Reagan I know it wasn't
Reagan was incredibly similar to this I
mean aside from the the crazy sexual
stuff his whole thing was make America
great again he's making America great
again he put a wreath on a Nazis grave
and he he did this Star Wars [ __ ] like
Reagan was out of his [ __ ] mind and
so were the people around him and it is
very similar yeah yeah it's it's cool
think is cool is a cool time
I just want to say I want to read this
you had talked or whatever you do I just
can't I just can't it's like it's also
got a little bit of a hint of Tea Party
to it too like with just with the sense
of extremely organized playing to you
know a section and being very very
[ __ ] aggressive and you know that
that works yeah there are so many
factions today that it's like it's hard
to even know I mean it still is crazy
that we're represented by two parties Oh
I mean how ya know I did but that's just
the way the system is I never gonna get
away from that so we have a couple of
friends who are dropping a new podcast
today two very very very funny comedians
who are married Natasha Leggero Oh Moshe
kasher their new show the endless
honeymoon podcast starts today and it's
a mix of stories from their marriage
they have game segments they have their
callers callers calling in asking for a
relationship advice and whatnot so I'm
gonna play a clip right now and then
after that click on the link in the
description for their new podcast the
endless honeymoon on Apple podcasts
Natasha Leggero and Moshe kasher very
very funny people through my favorite
comedian also very nice people yeah they
are very nice people
so I'm gonna play that right now if it
comes up
probably had this ready is it always
amping it's just downloading yeah oh
I'll just cut this out oh okay oh [ __ ]
alright I'll just drop in later well